how's the gum resumes welcome to sanic
infi alright i played my fair share of
unfair games so I know more or less
black to xscape back everything I don't
even know how to jump okay here we go
this should be fine right hey that one
is evil see I knew it god damn it I
didn't know it dies - I have dies twice
oh come on alright this one is fine it's
all got it
the spikes are good nope come on it's
this is not unfair this is just [ __ ]
stupid why does sonic you jump back up
again to show that he died it's like hey
guys I'm dead
could it just jumps up to save my life
but I just wanted to say that I'm [ __ ]
bad now holding feet Kim don't jump on
anything except that one [ __ ] you
alright I got [ __ ] every goddamn blue
Wow
oh there we go there's a ring
how about if not everything in this God
forbidden [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't kill
me
come on give me a break
there we go did I do it yeah
easy oh my god so easy
oh I click the restart alright it's
alright I know how to do this just give
me a couple more tries two thousand
years later yeah don't press our best
game ever tonight [ __ ] hell
oh come on I can't walk anyway oh you
what what what come on how much shut up
all right what do we do
I forgot for [ __ ] sake this game hates
you with a passion man what okay
of course it is easy just focus you've
got this one two three four
how am I supposed yes and not what will
kill me next who knows I'm so excited -
oh shut up well okay what do I do now
what do I do now
I don't know what a little what do I do
I'm Sanok I'm Sanok I'm sanic sanic go
[ __ ] who gave birth to this
abomination the sanic is an orphan it's
a Titanic is that what you all I I feel
bad for you then insane
that one is a liar that means Agra hide
by block that's just a true fool okay I
trust you can I trust you I trusted it
well easiest game ever thank you [ __ ]
you
come on all right
wretched ass vicious man mother of
totems here we go
yes not you who can you trust you can't
trust anyway I don't trust you I don't
trust a palm tree oh it was easy
bring it fish is easy hey
who built a robot piranha that will jump
up from the ocean to kill you
it's actually pretty genius I'll take
that back I want one now mom mom mom mom
no now now
[ __ ] you spikes yeah why the hell am I
supposed to jump come on oh oh oh
[Music]
old get that y'all get that fellow
what's a jab love me get aa helluva this
jab love but six and a half hours later
[ __ ] okay we're back no big deal love
this going by the way it's one of my
favorites it's an instant classic
software with Mozart Beethoven and and
DJ scrotum why are they fire bolts about
fire balls do not balance like that last
time I checked I never checked to be
honest I feel a little bad that I lied
to you
goddamnit go how hard is it seriously
there we go
don't you pen it
many hours on teleporter a unique you
get all right nobody found buddy you
know man named awesome cattle about
tolling any age a-comin oh great
I have to replay oh great
oh great Oh fantastic that's fair yeah
that's fair
look at this [ __ ] don't press our you
watch elite dad okay I got this
nope check tennis you didn't shake daddy
there we go nice shaking good job all
right
I don't even go into it I don't
understand why it penetrates me easy
this game so easy oh my god look I'm
speedrunning this [ __ ] Wow look how easy
oh my god [ __ ] so easy
Jason so easy so easy this game ever
look at that [ __ ] so easy so easy
mine is there a harder difficulty to
this game cuz I don't think it was hard
enough shake them
I don't care if you have them or not
just take them what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do here now maybe easy you
actually hurt that's how it's done
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
there we go easy look at this [ __ ]
I'm born to be a Sanok ah I'm a born
born side god damn it lava whoa whoa
that's how it's done
the bottom one [ __ ] you the bottom line
the graphics are soaked [ __ ] you it's
almost bad gooder than the ps4 above
mellow [ __ ] it hijo what's with the ice
blocks Jax I'll show you what's hard my
sanic right jab La Niebla this whatever
yep Lara what a blizzard better hello
you dope ah oppa oppa you're over your
sonic sonic sorry why shouting you
[ __ ] idiot why's that
you gotta make face you gotta go fast
sanic yatta classy all right oh yeah
yeah but ah man Wow
so what are you doing sanic what are you
doing sanic sanic sanic it's any good
sandy sanitize my aesthetic
oh yeah oh yeah
yeah oh Jenny
see naked men I now understand why
people die I get it now I get it
sanic Satan it's practically the same
thank you ha seriously what is this Oh
God
all right
hey go what are you doing you're not
saying it again so much sanic in the air
tonight I love it I love you Sonny I
want to have your babies we'll call them
faith and oh that jump oh my
sanic sanic sanic get yours yeah Sammy I
was disgusting I just threw up in my
mouth a little bit
thanks cynic Oh God Vijender what the
[ __ ] Ibaka what is they final Orson
Ellis nella
many paid off Victor I won't let you
have my baby sanic if you keep what the
[ __ ] was that I guys stop eating that I
can't I can't
Edgar I can't handle two sonic [ __ ]
at the same time God guide you have it
hey don't shine
I know how much what am I supposed to do
about the flames with that your honor
I always think he's such an [ __ ] what
I don't understand how do you dodge an
[ __ ] that's impassable
okay okay see what what am I doing with
my life
I'm sandy - [ __ ] it what if that lace
I'd go in from out of nowhere spaces
sanic what are you doing sanic what are
you doing sanic sanic sanic sanic oh
honey oh how my baby oh god at Senate
how [ __ ] hard can it be to [ __ ]
sanic it's not even hard man it's not
even hard man it's not even hard man
[ __ ] you basic skills on the hills
literally the hills not that lanky MTV
show the hills [ __ ] hills and ass you
think you're sanic but then you don't
know you know you think you're [ __ ]
Sonic the [ __ ] cut is he gonna do
what you gonna do about it
ah you did that about it how you did
that about it that's ok with me go go
gotta go so face said it goes off face
oh my god so face
so faced
so fast give me the Emerald I've got the
Emerald I got the Emerald like a Tamra
[Music]
thank you thank you very much for making
this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] like and
subscribe and I will next episode snort
a bunch of coke see ya few inches late
he'll have such a headache it's game
give me a headache hurts I don't know
don't this game is [ __ ] up man
don't play it ok